[Music]
and in Cambodia news Cambodia land of
the casinos so he calls Vegas Cambodia's
submitted by Al es a disagreement over
gambling led to a fatal stabbing oh damn
that's a pretty normal sense yes next
next article please people submitted it
they wanted us to talk about it if you
[ __ ] let you know what no matter how
common it is I'm still interested
because this is very very it's it's like
one of those things were like cheating
gossip all these like things that always
happens like but it's just I want to
hear it my uncle died that way
oh that shot yeah they were playing
cards we're gonna Mexico no was here
[Music]
okay I pictured I picture like a like a
Western with the [ __ ] donkey outside
no and I pictured your uncle like with a
sombrero and a [ __ ] poncho oh yeah
and then I saw like a John Wayne
[ __ ]
like they're playing cards and then
they're just [ __ ] shooting no nothing
it was here like her uncle
are you Mexican yeah um yeah that day
they were playing poker trying to figure
out what she was and then this my uncle
kept winning and this white dude that
really pissed John Wayne yeah he left he
came back with the gun shot him come
uncle I never met him dip his money yeah
he robbed about everyone else there I
don't know that's crazy
that's wilder be good cut yeah Oh
piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah so this play
this I like my story way better was
cuter yours are than a fantasy world I
pictured a lot of cactus to that I look
way better right yeah man I got sad from
here bugging uncle story did you tell
your murder story way funnier next time
shooting each other behind a cactus
doubt
[ __ ] I'll make my [ __ ] more [ __ ]
Disney exercise only funny murder
stories okay oh yeah and then to
conclude it there was a bunch of me will
come everywhere this guy now what are
you talking
now it's the story come on milk come
didn't make sense no balloon the city in
New York City like where wherever that
being happen now this is if this is
happening here like in LA whatever you
need something way I forgot to mention
my my uncle was a full-time job a clown
that was his job really yeah and he was
in costume when it happened dude that's
even more sad because now all the kids
that he made happy like there's no more
waiting girl don't fit anymore because
it's too real like the balloons don't
fit because it's too real and then the
mule come doesn't fit but it's Mexican
end this video no thanks anyway I'm so
very interested in this story Tiffany
finally we're gonna have some silence or
no I need the right notes no it was
better okay so this takes place in
Illinois there was this disagreement
over video gambling winnings I don't
really know that means but apparently it
was this poker mr. Bern and these two
guys were there one of the men told the
victim or so the guy that shot him told
the victim that how to bet on the
machine to win more money and then
that's when the victim took the man's
advice winning 150 dollars home then
that's when the man that give advice
demanded a part of the winnings oh but
then the victim said no so then they
ended up going it led to an argument
they went outside the dude shot the
victim I think it was less than that I
was Oh 20 bucks oh you wanted with your
right just Americans just want to shoot
each other all day honey but but that's
crazy so um yeah shoot shoot first think
literally you just proved you just think
like if I shot this person what's gonna
for me it's just like in the moment I
have to shoot them because I my balls
are bigger I have to prove that but then
it's like okay now what he's got all my
friends are like that oh no just people
like me
I know put it better hit this I mean
there's a lot though
there are a lot like that yeah that's
true no no I don't do that I like I like
to try and make the other everybody's
like that but it's still not like it's
so super weird to me whereas like even
Americans don't like that are like yeah
that's pretty normal
well like how it's so comments
normalized because we got a lot of
dumbasses like a lot like oh well this
country was built on a bunch of thieves
and crooks so you know come about Canada
like that that did it happened there's a
lot of crazy people again there's still
racism makanda like I mean that's not I
saw this video of some American
influences a lot of the racism in Canada
a lot of the reasons that I went through
was after 9/11 and that's because
America influenced that whole thing like
the orchestra any time you see like a
turban and a beard on TV it's like Osama
and his boys and so like anytime
somebody's determined beard it's like oh
you're that thing I saw on TV you're
gonna have your back
there's Indian guys that got killed here
in LA because people thought that they
were Muslim you know what people think
I'm Muslim all the time no assistance
since 9/11 it's like and before that the
racism was like Oh a poo ha ha like taxi
driver but then half of that was like
you're [ __ ] terrorists you murdered
children plumber monkey is that weird
part in the different racism and that's
because America influenced the racism
for the rest of the world so we got that
Canadians like the racist Canadians came
out and were like [ __ ] all these guys
like get a mess up America does leaflets
a lot of people boys hey hey hey you
like hamburgers though yeah there you go
sure yeah hamburgers boom we win
everybody says like la German food
hamburgers actually our German is a
German belly we know Americans perfected
it I think so I think yes I mean it
works like hot dogs you made worse
whereas like hot dogs are German like
you have the the sausage and there's
much more flavor you guys America has a
much bigger impact than you think and
that resonates with it oh yeah sure I
know yeah yeah I mean yeah I think it
there's a lot that goes into it like
we're actually we know more than a lot
of the [ __ ] it it's it's so it's it's
pretty bad like so I'm at I actually
know geography compared to like the
average American where like that's
already bad because I don't know that
much so for example like I know where
the [ __ ] on OA is you know and then if
you ask a lot of people here it's not
it's also not their fault because
they're not taught any of yeah there's
none there's a lotta to do America a lot
of you need to know about anything out
stuff from America this is what America
is and all you need is Vegas has
everything dude there's little Paris in
there we have like a rifle tower come on
now we have little France halls early
exactly we got everything there's many
more like Sydney those Atlantic City
it's so weird for Sacramento assignment
reversed man like my city grew it was so
so when that 9/11 stuff happened I don't
remember a single account of anybody
parading any like Muslim or brown kid
ever because that's not what happened
with me like we are all the broad
concern my town we got our asses kicked
we got like like it was like we I grew
up in a small Canadian city and like we
got so much [ __ ] like that's [ __ ] up I
had like my dad is like a big landscaper
he has all his plans ripped out my dad
was like so sad it's so weird because
like there's hard-ons like everything
would get ripped out we get like egged
and like it's just like you know I was
like scared to walk with my dad in
public because I didn't want people to
know he was my dad cuz I tell like I was
like I don't want to hang out
my dad in public everybody is gonna
think he's a sama cuz he like has a
turban and a beard I'm like they don't
know the difference you know so it's
like because I remember the jokes that
people would make but in like I don't
think in my school people got beat up
for that it was my school had like 2%
white people I also grew up in a very
low income like I went to this very low
income school it's like dumb people like
it was the white trash of Canada yeah
yeah I grew up in like I went to the
white trash school szczepan but they're
the ones really like pushing a lot of
that like and they're the most vocal you
know it's not educated straight up yeah
yeah that's what it was you know
well-traveled and diverse like it's not
those types and I think it's hard to
contain it cuz there's just a lot of
there's just a lot of people here just
population wise and also there's a lot
of vocal people here so then they don't
reflect the thoughts of all of America I
think we just we're super diverse and
there's so many different schools of
thoughts but it's also like a constant
battle that's happening even within here
of who's controlling you know the
government and who's going where yeah so
the night I've really resonated with you
I'm washing tonight up and I was
terrified yeah cuz I'm like this can
happen I come pero ya cuz I'm like this
could happen to me like and it's like it
was so believable cuz like I've been
through like [ __ ] that you know I mean
it's like yeah that's why nine of them
like man this is its it was very scary
to watch that show at home so this is
the victim of the shooting of the
gambling thing that we're talking about
this is 24 years old
you gotta gamble damn dude killer Oh
expect that forty years old and he just
for twenty dollars cuz he wanted 20
bucks he shoulda gave him 20 dollars man
is that jail time pajamas I think that I
haven't seen stripes in a long time I
don't think you would on this like in
his closet I don't look like if it they
don't really look like jell-o striped
pajamas you look looks like it's like so
what don't want that 20
imagine if that really is is attitude
how many other people need killing
eating your coupler I used to play a lot
of Poker and sometimes you know you'll
see the weirdest things at like 3 a.m.
and pretty much without fail
almost every single night you will hear
some person arguing at the top of their
[ __ ] lungs with the with the with a
like casino manager or something about
some kind of issue that went down and
they're like pissed and it's like so
many [ __ ] emotions go around
especially when it comes to gambling and
people with like gambling addictions and
stuff I think like it just they're
losing their house and there's just
there's just a lot of craziness
it's like reflection of their own
problems into this yeah and I think like
things like this it's like you know
that's why people get into fights and
all that stuff it always goes down
especially Ike in the parking lot I'm
like oh you [ __ ] did this and it's so
stupid because really it's just a game
right like that
yeah they're so attached to one thing
it's like you sometimes gonna let some
[ __ ] go and be like whatever yeah and
their buzz are drunk and you know that's
why I think everyone small and angry
there's so much anger and like hurt
inside and that comes out and like
violence you know like they're not
thinking clearly they're just yeah they
want to do it so kind of it's like
subconsciously you want other people to
feel your pain yeah because you're know
and that's why they're there at the
casino and you don't know what it's like
to not have paint yeah so you wanted
everyone to it's like you know like
misery loves company
yeah so yeah I'm saying in the negative
feed they dis- attracts negative no yep
and I'm just like I just want to eat
prime rib and Gamble guys come on let's
start to knew that so your intention of
gambling is completely different you
just like I won't have fun but you have
no like deep underlying issue and trauma
attached no it's especially poker man
pokers like fun yeah it's a pro game
yeah but other people may take a layer
too serious
[Music]
[Music]